here's a real question who's all playing
Pokemon go Matt's doing we don't know
how does that Pokemon go like that you
having fun over there bud I'm trying to
configure a PC okay well a paper
how many many parts are you gonna get
I'm gonna have 1080 GG X's SLI they a
noobs how many okay so Matt's clearly
not he was so into it for so long and
now he's just like that I can't even see
my screen to break out of the world that
I just launched a possible that I it's
so difficult to catch things now my god
it's really upsetting oh my god come on
Beckford you guys don't take her my
point minute where are you going
what's happening I didn't get back to my
computer for a quick second evil he
doesn't eat sushi Jenna doesn't he go
she has never eaten meat in her entire
life even when I was really young like
my parents are treaded like it would
present me with meat the meat
presentation do it there's something
monumental going on right now and your
head where's your hat really okay Reba
don't you - the other day I was like I
don't think I've ever seen look I can't
back with what and without a hat though
Kobe honey there was a guy there that is
level 30s name's Ian he was amazing he
had so many high-level Pokemon but now
we're scoping out the ground because
Jordan is gonna do a backflip hey do you
me to film it for you sure okay which
angle is right a double film oh well yes
did you land and crap though any dog
crap no good you're good
and literally at the counter trying to
catch pokemon and everything's running
like a piggy get ready
it might be life changing
fries need robust guys look what I got I
don't I didn't have one of these before
it looks like one of those like Teddy
Grahams that are dipped in chocolate
this looks like gum for rude yes I think
so yes this says lightly bike lane
trying out the Segway ninebot mini
the lights are so good
Oh
are we trespassing there an age limit
wait good Segway you can do bad on that
I mean no your I'll do it I'll try it I
think we're less worried about how it
turns out on video and more worried if
you're in the hospital but pull myself
up so I might get hurt so he had so much
fun hunting Pokemon last night and now
this morning I was just going through
sort of my little pokédex and figuring
out what I can get rid of but I can't
get rid of and it looks like I've got a
little evolution here that I can do give
me something good give me something good
oh look how cute you are
you sound terrible quite terrifying
actually
yeah register it I may be someone whoa
what's that
buta more 1090 are not so bad no so bad
Jayda buggies yesterday Jen no really
Matt quick plate can you believe it
crazy there was the UPS delivery so
before I go I wanna show you guys my
pokedex what I've got I don't think I've
ever even giving you guys an update it's
a little look at what we've got going on
here you're gonna make friends
pretty proud of the sizer
I actually hatched him it's got nine
tails yesterday as well who I know got
some eggs hatching we're good to go
okay thanks for watching let me know
what your top rated Pokemon is and I'm
gonna go out at this video yeah you're
behind here's the bedroom dilemma the
bed doesn't quite match up with the
dresser which kind of is driving me
crazy